Herkese
merhaba ben doktor Seçil Günay Avcı
kadın hastalıkları ve doğum uzmanıyım
diye Öğretim üyesiyim bir kadınım bir
eşim bir anneyim
yıllar önce Üniversite Sınavı tercihleri
sırasında tıp fakültesine girişim
babamın isteğiyle olmuştu altı senelik
zorlu bir püf eğitiminden sonra kazandım
kadın doğum bölümünü sevinç içinde
kutlarken babamın sistemle karışık
tepkisini hiç unutamıyorum
Bana artık kadın sağlığı uzmanı
olacaksın bu durumda en çok isteyen
benken bir tek bana bakamayacak bu işte
aslında kadın sağlığı erkek sağlığında
birebir etkileyen bölümlerden bir tanesi
sadece kadınlar arası da sadece Erkekler
arasında değil Kadınlar Arasında da
maalesef kadın hastalıkları ve doğum
uzmanlığı çok dar bir kapsamda ve sadece
doğum uzmanı olarak algılıyor Hatta
doktorluğu mu elini yaşlarda bir
hanfendi Mesleğimi öğrendiğinde şöyle
diyebiliyor anne güzel meslek ama Bizden
geçti artık ya da eski sizi daha önce
tanışsaydık kızımız artık on altı yaşına
geldi 16 yıl önce tanışsaydık sizi
diyebiliyorlar
belki 50'li yaşlarda bir hanfendi için
menopoz kadın sağlığının en uzun ve en
verimli dönemi olan menopozlu Yıllar son
derece önemli örnek mi
1094 yaşındaki İngiliz kraliçesi Elsa
Evet at üstünde dimdik Osteoporoz yok
Şok'tan sağlık
vücudun mutluluk ve esenlik halidir
Vücudun ve ruhu
bir kadın cinselliğini yaşarken sağlıklı
ise bir kadın hamile kalırken sağlıklı
ise bir kadın hamile kaldığında düşük
yapmıyorsa hamileliğinde mutludur tağlık
lıdır bir kadın doğum yaşarken doğum
yaparken sorun doğumdan sonra
tükenmişlik hali yaşıyorsa Bu kadının
sağlığından ve mutluluğundan
bahsedemeyiz
böyle bir kadınla aynı evi paylaşan Kedi
bile mutlu değilken
eşi ve çocukları Mutlu olabilir mi
Bebeği unutmayalım kediye daha sonra
tekrar geleceğiz o
kadın sağlığı demişken bir odan
bahsetmeden olmaz
kadın sağlığında kilo son derece önemli
Neden Çünkü
bu dünya çiş manlı izleme biriminin
ülkemizle ilgili bir tespiti var Türkiye
Avrupa'nın e obez Ülkesi derecesini
yıllardır bu kutlarken bir derece daha
aldı Avrupa'nın en fazla şeker hastası
olan Ülkesi
Bu ne demek ki Türkiye'de her üç
yetişkinden biri fazla kilolu ya da obez
peron yetişkinden biri de çeker hastası
maalesef
peki bunun kadın sağlığı ile ne ilgisi
var
bu Türkiye'de
kadınlarımıza baktığımızda da her dört
kadınımız dan biri fazla ki 34 kadınımız
dan biri bi endokrin ve metabolizma
Derneği ile bir araştırma yapmış 78
yaşındaki ilkokul 2'nci sınıfa giden her
dört çocuktan biri de fazla kilolu veya
şişman bulunmuş
anneler kilolu bu çocuklar kilolu
Cerrahpaşa'da bir hocamız vardı bize şey
derdi kadın kiloluysa Evdeki kedi bile
şişmandır bize geldik mi Yine kediye
ilkokul 2. sınıf Ben ilkokul 2.
sınıftayken
Ege'nin şirin bir Kasabası olan
Milas'ın Güllük köydeydim günlük bir
Balıkçı köyüdür günlük İlkokulu'nda iki
sınıfta dersin önce saniye öğretmenimiz
bizi bahçeye çıkarır bahçede sabah sporu
yaptırdı sabah sporundan sonra hep
birlikte tekrar dersimizde girerdik bu
ve okul bahçesi Tıpkı
Japonların meditasyon bahçesi gibiydi
78 yaşındaki çocuklar 78 yaşındaki
çocuklar şişman Sayar geri 8 yaşındaki
ilkokul 2'nci sınıfa giden çocuklar da
ergenlerde fazla kilo varsa bu
çocuklarda başka sorunlar yer almaz mı
Tabii ki
2018'de yine Türkiye'de çok güzel bir
araştırma yapılmış 30 tane obez şişman
çocuk ve ergen alınmış ve onların ruhsal
durumlarına ve ailelerinin tutumlarına
bakılmış bu çalışmadan çıkan 3 çarpıcı
sonuç var
biri şişman obez fazla kilolu dediğimiz
çocuk ve ergenlerin Anneleri sağlıklı
gruba göre daha bu daha kilolu
22 Bu çocukların ailelerinin ebeveyn
tutumlarının yani yaşam kalitesi
sağlıklı yaşam algıları diğerlerine göre
daha zayıf 3 Bu çocuklarda katric
hastalıklar ruhsal hastalıkların
rastlama olasılığı daha fazla ruhsal
adlı sizofreni paranoya takıntı dikkat
eksikliği hiperaktivite bozukluğu
beden algı bozukluğu
beden algı bozukluğu çok önemli Eğer bir
kadın çocuğunu ya da Ergen olacak kişiyi
şişmanlıktan fazla kilodan korursa Demek
ki beden algı bozukluğundan da
koruyabilir
beden aldı bozukluğunu günümüzde neyle
görüyoruz aşure estetikler
eğer biz çocuklarım
bu
sağlıklı beslenmeye kaliteli yaşamaya
adapte dersek fazladan ve gereksiz
estetik müdahalelerinde Belki daha en
baştan önüne geçebiliriz
Evet beden algı bozukluğunun haricinde
bize Parkı'nda olmadan yerleştirilen
negatif algılar da var mı kendinizle
ilgili kadınlarla ilgili özellikle
kadınları pis kusurlu gibi gösteren
kadınların farklılıklarını negatif
algıla tane önemli örneklerden bir
tanesi de Türk Dil Kurumu
Türk Dil Kurumu'na baktığımızda Türk Dil
Kurumu'nda
kirli kelimesinin karşılığında sözlükte
aybaşı durumunda bulunan kadın yazıyor
negatif toplumsal bir Klişe
Peki bu böyle olursa ilkokul 2 bu
dönelim gene 7-8 yaş çocuğu açtı sözlü
baktı kirli karşısına aydasu durumunda
kadın
Bunu gören çocuk artık Kaç yaşına
gelirse gelsin kaç üniversite bitirirse
bitirsin kaç yüksek lisans yapıp kaç dil
öğrenirse öğrensin bizim karşımıza
geldiğinde su cümleyi kuruyor ayın
3'ünde kirlendim ayın 7'sinde
temizlendim kirlendim temizlendim Biz
çünkü
şu İşte biz biz maalesef ülkemizdeki
resmi bir dil kurumu baskısıyla 78
yaşındaki çocuklarımıza da adet görmeyi
pis dalgınlığı kusur gibi algıla
atıyoruz hepimiz elde eliyle tüm toplum
olarak
bak Evet biz kadınlar hala yan
varlıklarız
yıllardır tarih ötesinden beri
ürkütülmüş kana Bu pek çok insanı
kadının kanaması korkutmuş tarlalardan
komşular Eskiden bereketini sürüyor
bereketini kaçırıyor tarlanın diye
yapmışlar kadınları Cadı diye yıllarca
biliyorsunuz şifacı diye
Komik geliyor değil mi Şu anda saçma
sapan geliyor Kadın adet olmuş tarzının
bereketi niye Kaçırsın diye ama acaba Şu
anda Bizim
yaptığımız daha ne kadar taşmalık var da
bir sonraki nesiller bizi
yargılayacaklar hiç biliyor muyuz Hiç
düşündük mü burada yaptıklarımızı
yapıyor olduklarımızı bizden sonraki
nesiller bize dair neleri saçma
bulacaklar acaba
Halbuki kadın ve erkek arasında farklar
vardır Evet ve bundan bütün hayrınadır
kadın mesela sözel gücü yüksektir
o kadın 20000 kelime ile konuşurken
erkek 7000 kelimeyle konuşur Yani bir
kadın erkeği Üç katı fazla kelime ile
konuşabilir Neden Çünkü dedikodu önemli
bir doğru erkeği seçme yöntemidir Öyle
değil mi Öyle güzel tanımlar ki
Konuşurken
kadınlar Evet sözler güçleri erkeklerden
yüksek başka kadınlar da müthiş bir
hormon metabolizması vardır mesela adet
olmak adet olmak pislik kirli kanamak
diye bakıyoruz ama adet olur olmaz
kadında Öz çocuğum başlar
yumurtladığında yanına da progesteron
eklenir hem de Yüksek dozda
özsözen progesteron bunlar böyle
birlikte ki derken Rahmi çok güzel bir
şekilde
potansiyel gelecek söylenecek bebek için
hazırlarlar rahmin kan akımını
arttırırlar rahim için dokusunu
geliştirirler yatak bu gelen kanıtı mı
savunma hücreleri ile kök hücreleri
getirir adet kanında kök hücresi vardır
bu gelen savunma hücreleri ve kök
hücresi
dönecek olan bebeğin kalitesini aldılar
eğer sakatsa düzgün bir bebek değilse
hemen atar dışarı yani kadın düşük yapar
var peki dönmedi yumurta spermi buluşma
the O zaman ne olur o zaman bu
hazırlanmış bebek için potansiyel ya tak
tak kasılır birden ve dışarıya atılmak
için hazırlanır nasıl östrojen ve
progesteron sahneden çekilir perde
kapanır Rahim kasları kasılıp o yatağa
önce Rahim ağzından soru vajinada
dışarıya tane olur Kadın adet görmüş
olur bu
O ne lan etli olacak kirli olacak bir
durum değil aslında da erkeklerin ile
kadın arasındaki farklardan bir tanesi
daha icat ettiyse bir gebelik Doğum ve
emzirme dir Bu dönemlerde ise kadının
hormonları ve cümbüş halindedir
başroldeki östrojen ve progesteron abi
de plesanta hormonları eklenir plesanta
bebeğin eşi diyebiliyor halk arasında
plesanta hormonları kadını Ama birlikte
şekere meyilli krallıklar
gerçekten çeker e yatkın olmak meyilli
olmak hamile niz ve bebeğin yaşamsal
riskini artırır İşte o yüzden bizim
hamilelerde çeker yükleme testini ihmal
etmememiz çok önemli
hamilelik aynı zamanda kadın sağlığının
kadın hayatının riski atı bir dönemdir
hem de Amirlik şekeri tespit etmek için
şeker yükleme testi yapmazsak anne
karnındaki bebeklerin sağlığından Emin
olamayız Hatta hayatlarını
kaybetmelerine de sebep olabiliriz ve
hayatlarını kaybeden Bu bebekler
Genellikle hep Zavallı Kordon
etraflarını boyunlarına dolandı diye
suçlanarak kaybederler ve karşımıza
bazen karnındaki bebeği 7 8 kere
kaybetmiş ama hiç şeker testi yapılmamış
kadınlar geliyor O kadar üzücü bir durum
ama hiç test yapılmadan devam ediyor her
şey ve şöyle Ali Kordon var Hep aynı
kadının aynı sefer bebeğine dolar Hep
aynı kordu aynı kadına dolanıyor gibi
olması mümkün mü değil tabii ki o yüzden
hamilelikte şeker ve şeker yükleme testi
bizim için çok önemli Tamam kadın Öz o
zaman progesteronu var plesanta
hormonları geldi galaksinin de var Kadın
da Prolaktin sütü sağlıyor hamilelikte
amirlikten Ken kadını süt için
hazırlıyor
arkadan oksitosin geliyor oksitosin
iftarda qform onu bebekle annenin bağını
güçlendiriyor
sonra dopamin zevk veriyor kadına
emzirirken emzirmeyi Bırakamıyor bir
türlü anneler
adrenalin duymuşsunuzdur hep böyle
uykuyu kaçırır işte askerlere verilir
saldırganlıkta birazcık sağlar adrenalin
müthiş bir enerji veriyor kadına doğumda
inanılmaz enerjik oluyor anneler
yaptırdım bir sürü doğumda çok sıklıkla
rastlarım kadının o enerjisine o kadar
sancı çeker uykusuz dur mahvolmuş
durumda bebeğini kucağına aldığı anda
inanılmaz bir enerji inanılmaz ve
mutluluk hisseder anneler
o kadınla erkeğin farkı doğumda da
ortaya çıkar Bu sırada doğma eşlik eden
kadının yanında olan ona destek veren
babalarımız doğum biter bitmez
rahatlarlar böyle bir mutlu olurlar bir
rehavet çöker ve Dayı hafifçe uygulamaya
geçerler kadının ama Cin gibidir enerjik
tirhala adrenalin etkisinde
Bu da benim doğumumdan bir fotoğraf
cin gibi böyle sakinleşmiş haldeyiz
Evet kadın sağlığı a erkek sağlığı
ailenin sağlığı Toplum Sağlığı demektir
bir Türk kadına hak ettiği değeri bi pek
çok çağdaş ulustan önce sağlayan Mustafa
Kemal Atatürk der ki
insan topluluğu kadın ve erkek
o cins insandan oluşmaktadır
Bu mümkün müdür ki bu kütlenin bir
parçasını ilerletelim
ötekini ihmal edelim de kütlenin bütünü
hep birlikte ilerleyebilsin
mümkün müdür ki bir cismin yarısı
toprağa zincirlerle bağlı kalırken öteki
kısmı göklere yükselebilsin
kadın sağlığını
mutlak kılmanın
toplum sağlığının ve
çağdaşlaşmanın olmazsa olmaz kuralı
olduğunu bilen Biz kadın sağlığı
çalışanları
bu açtığın yolda gösterdiğin hedefe hiç
durmadan yürüyeceğimiz E az içeriz
varlığımız tüm kadınlara armağan olsun
Çok
teşekkürler Ah bak